and people whilst Isis hi all my name is
Ellie beer living as well and i
represent United hot sell off all those
r us is just which is a corresponding
change shoes throughout Israel volunteer
only and I get the social orange ability
year from the military field and I want
to require an answer to swati from
Mumbai to ask the question what is the
one filled in 2012 you would like to see
happen in the world as well but i did in
israel is something that won't happen
along guard post I didn't Israel connect
his people it was the motorcycles you
know we have a lot of commercially
between people is where we have Jews
marriage and questions and even Sikhs
and other religions will all come to
Israel and we have to learn to live with
each other because if not have disasters
and we do have a lot of problems that's
in my way I just created a system where
in any emergency if someone got figured
is choking or heart attack or oxido to
our bamaca we have thousands of
volunteers throughout Israel world
professional harmonic communities in the
respond in seconds to any emergency from
their home or from the earth and they go
directly to the emergency builders we
have a technology which was created by
our force in Israel which connects these
people to on to the location where the
calls needed where someone is choking
the the person who is there was to
prepare until this Charles choking less
press the by the emergency right move
automatically know where they are or
they can call us and they were we would
automatically know where they are and we
would send the closest paramedics the
animal so many times you would find 20
minutes from of Jewish and they would go
respond to a child whose Mars or vice
versa we would have a Moslem volunteer
and United
who would respond to a chosen child
who's Jewish or Christian and he would
go save his life so we see that when it
comes to a disaster or tragedy in a
family where a child is choking or
sounds having a heart attack you know
really cute little sleepy you really
need someone to save it doesn't matter
if easily is and what color he is and if
he's white or black or yellow it doesn't
really matter so when someone is
bleeding today anyone that comes here
lightsabers life we really make the
change so I'm saying something about the
world I love this world to really care
about each other when they have a
disaster in any country in the world
every country should offer their help
anyone that could for instance we in
Israel offer our help to Iran when I had
an earthquake so unfortunately they said
locals and thousands of people were
trapped underneath it buildings a
collapse but they didn't want help from
us but we were really even so funny
politically we don't get along at all
but you know it the people who were
trapped underneath these buildings
needed help and we have the most
professional rescue list in the world
there you go no doubt we helped save
hundreds and thousands of people we
saved our honorable expression now in
Haiti we are we sent troops engineering
for health so there I why don't we have
a better world where we can think about
you know forget about all the
governments in oil politics let's
connect people that as a respite of
people from from Saudi Arabia and Israel
revive and Pakistan in any way around
the world let's connect the people let's
have like like the Midlands let's have
an it works out like a social all you
see in coming up and saying let's
connect the people together forget about
the government's and maybe have no way a
new passport where the password will be
like a social passport and if you want
to go speak to someone in normal country
you don't need the government to allow
you to speak to another person
you just speak the other person in
hopefully by that when we respect each
other and know how to live with each
other and hopefully we'll have a better
world I so that was a great question and
I nearly all turn to some more questions
they serve in life thank you for the
world economic forum to see the strong
foundation to do what they like